hi everyone my favorite stammering and
I'm Cody Belcher and this is Tara Jessa
Cody also just saw two as well full-on
Winnie the Pooh II so we just saw a
Deadpool 2 and we're drinking
Mike's harder lemonade harder
Deadpool version we're gonna try not to
do any spoilers so there will be no
spoilers that sounded very much like if
you're lucky there won't be any spoilers
no spoilers for this general thoughts is
I thought it was fun I thought it was
funny I thought it was not as good as
the first but rarely sequels are and I I
had a really good time I thought there
were some really good moments some
really good action sequences the action
was stellar the fourth wall breaking was
great and there were some good
references biggest compliment is that
when the movie was over I looked at my
watch I was like oh wow that was like a
2-hour issue it felt way shorter which
sounds like a double was like a
double-edged sword compliment kind of a
deal it's not it meant like that it kept
me for what it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be a funny action movie it
kept my interest and it kept me laughing
and and engaged enough that I never
really considered how long it was and it
felt shorter I will say its biggest
drawback or weakness is that the best
part of the movie is in the credits
which is great the credits could stick
around for the mid credit it's hilarious
if you're someone who wants to see
Deadpool - you're going to definitely
love this but that is also definitely
the best part of the whole movie there
is so much fourth wall breaking yeah and
so many good references and such
self-aware like almost too self-aware at
points but it was really fun it was it
made me laugh out loud a lot of the
fight sequences do things that I've not
seen in Marvel films before and I think
that's really cool I really like that
yeah I would compare it to Watchmen stay
with me don't don't press the button up
stay on this stay in the video stay with
me for a second so Watchmen I feel like
with Zack Snyder just just transposing
at well not I don't feel like he was
actually doing it
transposing actual comic book pages
to the film but the the heart and energy
wasn't really in them this this more
than any other movie the comic-book
movie I've seen felt like the comic like
this felt like I read it because I grew
up reading Deadpool I have I have
Deadpool all the way from the very
beginning I think I said this last time
we did Deadpool a few of the jokes fell
flat I think because at a few moments
you could tell it was something that was
supposed I even thought like I wonder
what the premiere was like I wonder if
people laughed at this joke because no
one in our theatre did they were
supposed to laugh at it and there were
just a few of them and it felt like it's
because the whole film is just pushing
pushing boundaries and like doing things
that I ignore maleic you know actually
the film's don't - but like look at doc
kid we're like what what ignore me like
when they don't do it fully at every
single moment it kind of feels like it's
not good at that moment when it is and
they're just trying to incorporate maybe
some feeling or some depth to it other
than just like a fun surface level thing
where I feel like in the first film they
did that better you were able to have
some points of like feeling and you
really cared about things outside of
like when's the next joke coming where I
love the format of this movie and I
really like how much I laughed I really
liked how much I enjoyed it how it kept
my attention but I do think the first
one was able to achieve a little bit
more in that sense it's like if you're
watching like a Michael Bay movie if but
if the Michael Bay movie was just the
final fight scene the whole movie and
you're just like can we just have a
moment where Anthony Hopkins is talking
for a second please cuz I'm I need a
break it's how it kind of went yeah and
I feel like that's because we were like
want looking for something to talk about
enjoy cuz like if you're just going to
like have some popcorn and have a beer
before just enjoy the fuck out of this
film you're totally going to do it I
think it's super fun yeah it's
definitely worth seeing yeah like we
were saying on the ride home
I don't think I'll I'm not gonna go see
the skin in theatres but like it was fun
it I laughed out loud it did its purpose
yeah and it was a good sequel it was a
solid sequel he action sequences were so
good the first one starts off and you
get this beautiful action montage of him
beating up bad guys while nine to five
by Dolly Parton plays and it just is a
beautiful thing I think the soundtrack
is so wonderfully odd it's all very well
choreographed the fights are and it
doesn't feel like a blurry of shit
that's happening that you can't really
keep track of you could see everything
happening Michael Bay and and a lot of a
lot of like my favorite Marvel film of
this year obviously was black panther
and but a lot of the fights in black
panther were too dark or too light
blurry you couldn't really tell every
single move that was happening and in
this I felt like I could see everything
and also you feel what he breaks
something like if and he breaks his arm
and like he'll use that break in like
yeah the way that they use his power to
get fights and to get like the
choreography of the action this is down
I think it's really good yeah and I will
say going back to it that might be I'm
ik my I think the biggest weakness of
the film to me was that it was overly it
was like overly sad and like touching at
certain points where I was like okay we
don't really need to keep going back to
this but my mind was kind of changed in
the men's bathroom by some guys this is
that but I wasn't about I was waiting
line in the bathroom and what happens in
the Regal bathroom stays in the ring go
back that was not on the door and some
dudes came in and they were like man
that was a really touching movie bro and
I was like oh yeah I guess like that's
that's a motion for Bros like the type
of people could go and see like action
II movies aren't going and seeing like
you know I don't really I like they're
really the titanic's your emotional
yeah they're not really getting that
Billy Zane fix stuff we're gonna talk
about like you know masculinity which is
a thing that is addressed in the movie
as well yeah yeah that like these types
of like guys who go to see Deadpool are
probably not I'm not obviously I'm not
general I thinks I'm a guy because he's
Deadpool but like some of the bros that
are there who refer who's literally
saved the phrase that was really
touching bro are probably not you know
experiencing a lot of genuine emotion
and and and vulnerability in characters
that they look up to which I also don't
think you should really look up to
Deadpool but right the characters I
think are cool yeah it's nice to see
both cable and Deadpool are two
characters that are badasses that in
this movie were emotion driven yeah and
vulnerable very vulnerable and that's
super important I loved the assembling
of that team yeah and I love the team
that you get at the end of the film you
get a clear definition of what you're
gonna get in the third film if there is
a third film but it looks like there is
going to be obviously you get a very
clear vision of what that's gonna be and
it's I like it I'm not very into the
group also comment below Colossus and
Deadpool will they won't they the
question of the century
I say yes I love the the opening and
closing credits yeah well done though I
still don't understand when people leave
the second after a Marvel movie I guess
some people don't well I mean this is
totally this is technically a Fox movie
president presented with Marvel yeah so
maybe they just uninformed swine Domino
wait let's talk about domino domino the
Valkyrie of Deadpool the best pizza
place
[Laughter]
what I loved Domino's so much I did as
well I am into her as a character and
also into her eyes of girlfriends me too
Massa - they approached the luck thing
so well yeah I yeah that was really well
done and it was just the perfect amount
of comedy where she wasn't like - in
your face like Deadpool is so good so
well done I really enjoyed her I think
she was definitely my favorite character
in this
I wish there would have been more
negasonic teenage warhead it's hard to
say but to be fair they did say her
girlfriend's name several times that I
cannot remember it it's something with
an N Yuki some like that it was a fine
movie I enjoyed it I had fun I'm not
gonna write to my mom about it she
talked I want to see it what's the last
movie you wrote to your mom about secret
of NIMH thank you so much for watching
next I'm sorry next week is I think it
actually is I think that's early err
where you were like I don't know what it
is next weekend's like I think it takes
I remember going oh next week is that
I'm making a queer uh cosplay and I
don't think that's how you say your name
but I wish it was you're doing solo solo
I could be there is your Chewbacca thank
you for joining me thank you for having
me so much it was so lovely to have you
back to available at 7-elevens near you
everyone go follow cody on all of his
respective social medias that I will not
be linking below see you guys next week
[Applause]
[Music]